peu
[Musique]
leblanc 1956 et moins blanc que jamais
il devient encore plus fantaisistes
toujours plus gai il est rayé brodé
fleury imprimés comme c'est spirituel
mouchoir de couleur chaque mouchoirs
vaut 130 points le mouchoir calendrier à
choisir quand on est distraite
à moins que vous ne préfériez la bonne
humeur de cette anecdote
[Musique]
la joueuse emportera le joker est là
sentimentale la phrase qui l'a fait
rêver
[Musique]
rayon des nappes si vous êtes tenté par
la couleur pensait qu'elle devra
s'harmoniser avec les nuances de la
salle à manger
elle est verte cette nappe en coton
décorée de fougères andry mécanique 7500
francs pour six couverts cette nappe
créé mais en pure fil de lin c'est clair
des couleurs vives des fleurs des champs
[Musique]
ces broderies à jour et sont italienne
elle s'incruste dans une toile pur fils
7300 francs pour six couverts pour les
soirs de grande réception cette
somptueuse n'a blanche en toile pur fils
enrichi de jour et de broderie au point
de venise 43 mille francs pour 12
couverts d'un prix plus accessibles neuf
mille neuf cent francs pour six couverts
cette nappe ronde en toile delà d'un
bourreau soutenu en contraste broderies
blanches exécuté à la main
enfin si vous avez un intérieurs
rustiques ou tout simplement si le linge
basque vous plaît vous n'aurez que
l'embarras du choix
zébré de couleurs vives bordé de franges
ou relais à jour le linge basque et
d'une grande variété
[Musique]
mais l'idée nouvelle idée originale du
blanc 1956 c'est le torchon imprimés
avec ses fruits avec ses légumes avec
ses instruments de la vie ménagères de
teintes éclatantes
il est gay il est amusant il peut se
métamorphoser en un joyeux tablier le
l'âge est optimiste en 1956 il est aussi
pratique d'après le dessin choisi il dit
tout de suite son nom avec le torchon
imprimés vous ne confondrait plus le
torchon un casserole avec les suivait il
vaut 375 francs dans leur ensemble les
prix du blanc sont cette année en légère
baisse 3 5% par rapport à 1955
[Musique]